Avengers
Assemble
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie
you've probably seen a lot of websites
and Marvel actors participating in big
MCU rewatched series lately since we've
all mostly been stuck in our homes so a
lot of you requested I do a new video
series doing new breakdown videos and
Easter Egg videos for all the Marvel
movies in the Infinity Saga covering all
the details and deleted scenes that have
been uncovered teasing Marvel phase 4
stuff happening in the future going all
the way back to the Marvel phase 1
movies things setting up Avengers
infinity war Avengers endgame the
upcoming Marvel phase 5 stuff like
mutants x-men Deadpool the Fantastic
Four they've been so many deleted scenes
and details that Marvel has revealed in
the last couple of years about the early
phase 1 movies setting up x-men it's
crazy so I still have two giant infinity
saga box sets to giveaway of all the
blu-rays from all the movies what I'll
do is I'll give those away as part of
the video series originally I had
planned on doing that for the Black
Widow movie when it hit theaters in a
couple weeks but since that's been
delayed till November along with the
rest of the Marvel phase 4 movies I
don't want to wait till November to give
away the Infinity Saga box sets this is
what they look like on the inside not
only do they have all the blu-rays from
all the movies in 4k they also have a
special bonus disc with a bunch of
deleted scenes that have never been
released before I've done a couple
videos for those I'll link one of those
at the end of this what you need to do
to participate in that as part of this
big series it's just become a subscriber
if you aren't already and when I post
new breakdown and Easter Egg videos for
each of the MCU movies I'll be picking
the winners based on who I think leaves
the best most insightful comments
amongst the subscribers so it is more of
a contest than usual but the Infinity
Saga box sets are a really big deal
since I've got two of them we'll name
the first winner at the halfway point
we'll call that the video for Avengers
age of Ultron in terms of pacing I think
doing at least two Marvel movies per
week minimum seems like a good place to
start and I'll just adjust the pace and
how frequently I post them based on the
response from you guys the most
important thing you guys can do is just
make sure that you have alerts turned on
for my channel in order to get all the
videos and participate in the comments
for each movie just as a preview here's
some of the major things we've learned
in the years since some of these movies
have come out going all the way
to the Marvel phase one and Phase two
movies so just going down the list here
starting with Iron Man's father Howard
Stark having the space stone for a long
time without realizing it was an
infinity stone he only knew it as the
tesseract and by the time we got to Iron
Man 2 an Iron Man is trying to create an
arc reactor that won't poison him slowly
he uses Howard Starks research on the
tesseract to complete his father's
concept of a new element capable of
creating incredible amounts of clean
energy so wired man has effectively been
powering his arc reactors this whole
time
with the power of an infinity stone all
that research is based on the science of
the space stone it's a really clever way
to explain how he's been so powerful
this whole time and a good example of
how Marvel and Kevin Feige
in those early days had ideas for how
the story of the Infinity Saga might
play out but they always try to leave
room so that they can introduce new
ideas in the next movie to pay things
off in an even bigger way and say hey
we've been planning this cool twist the
whole time another good example is the
x-men the mutants in spider-man Easter
eggs in the original Iron Man
post-credit scene another really cool
example of them doing a huge easter egg
that changes the complete mythology of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe was the
first guardians of the galaxy movie
James Gunn recently just participated in
a rewatch of guardians of the galaxy and
said originally his movie didn't include
any of the fan oohs scenes or the
backstory on the Infinity stones that
the collector gave them he said that
those were parts that Marvel and Kevin
Feige asked him to add to the movie so
that it could continue setting up the
infinity saga of movies he said they
also told her to write an origin story
for the Infinity stones but didn't tell
him what the story should be or how he
should do that in that scene the origin
of the Infinity stones is probably one
of the biggest foundations for the
upcoming eternals movies
Thanos is back story in the cosmic
origin of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
talking about eternity in the idea of
the firmament if you're not a big comic
book reader or you're not familiar with
a lot of the big cosmic concepts in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe there are
actually characters who are cosmic
beings that wield near unlimited power
within the Marvel Cinematic Universe
there's this concept of multiple Big
Bang's so every New Era the universe
dies heat death
contracts and then Ari expands in
another Big Bang the Infinity stones are
the remnants of the previous version of
the universe that's why they're so
powerful they contain the power of an
entire universe distilled down into the
tiny form of those stones it's also the
explainer for how Galactus is so
powerful and where he comes from
that's all big Marvel phase four story
that they're going to get into during the
next ten years explaining who Galactus
is how he was created and how he's
related to the other Celestials like ego
the Living Planet everyone wants to know
about the Fantastic Four Silver Surfer
Galactus in the new MCU movies Galactus
actually used to be a humanoid man his
real name was Galen he used to be a
scientist from the previous version of
the main universe as his universe was
slowly dying and contracting getting
ready for another Big Bang he went to
study that and as it was happening he
was approached by the current version of
eternity at that time they made a pact
to survive then during the big bang that
created our current Marvel Cinematic
Universe they were reborn as Galactus
the single being we don't know which
movie Galactus is going to show up in
for the first time probably after they
debut the new version the Fantastic Four
but there is this big Galactus saga that
they can do now because they have access
to those characters even if you're not a
big comic book reader you probably
remember during guardians of the galaxy
to Peter quill has a vision of the
cosmic entity eternity when ego the
Living Planet awakens more of his
celestial abilities eternity is the
anthropomorphic being that encompasses
the entire universe were getting into
the multiverse during Marvel phase four
like Doctor Strange to the multiverse of
madness each different universe of the
multiverse has its own distinct version
of eternity and its own distinct version
of the Infinity stones the next really
cool a new detail at Easter Egg we
learned about long after these movies
came out is that during Avengers
infinity war there was actually a
deleted scene with the Living Tribunal
during that fight Doctor Strange was
going to send Thanos on the same cosmic
tour of the multiverse that the Ancient
Ones sent him on during the first Doctor
Strange movie in after Thanos crashed
his way through a bunch of different
dimensions Doctor Strange took him to be
judged by the Living Tribunal during
Iron Man 2 I was just talking about Iron
Man creating the new element based on
the Infinity stone to power his arc
reactors there's actually a deleted
scene
from that movie also setting up more
x-men stuff for Marvel phase four and
Marvel phase 5.
Tap the Oracle grid. I need some stuff out of storage.
Get me everything from projects pegasus Exodus
and Goliath get ready for a major
remodel!
All those things are actually setting up stuff
that they paid off in
future movies that we found out about
later so project Pegasus is actually
related to Captain Marvel it's all about
the base in them trying to use the
tesseract to create another infinite
energy source project Goliath was
something that shield was working on
with Goliath from the comics Laurence
Fishburne's character they finally paid
that off during ant-man and the wasp
project Exodus is all about setting up
the Eternals the biblical Exodus is and
them leaving society and setting up the
x-men characters obviously x-men are a
little further off but Marvel's Eternals
movie is going to recontextualize a lot
of other things and we're mutants come
from in the MCU in a little while ago I
did a breakdown of the footage that they
screened off from the movie showing some
of the character designs and the way
their powers work it's very similar to
the way the powers and the costumes of
the modern-day characters look so my
first video as part of this infinity
saga rewatched series will be the first
Iron Man movie that'll post in the next
couple of days as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you should
see the video when I post it and we'll
just see how it goes hopefully this
works and we get through all the
Infinity Saga movies all 23 everyone let
me know in the comments of this any
special requests you have as part of
this video series and there is some big
Marvel stuff coming up there'll be a
couple big trailers I know everyone
wants the venom 2 trailer but why you
wait for everything click here for my
breakdown of that new Eternals footage
and click here for my breakdown of that
black panther 2 teaser thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe I'll
see you guys tonight!